hello I'm John Legend and I'm Chrissy  Teigen and we're all set well GQ  describe the absolute worst date you  could possibly take her on where would  you go let's see a bad date well first  of all neither of us like live music  while we're eating oh my yeah so the  worst day for Chris would be allowed  live music right in front of us while  we're trying to have dinner like we both  hate that but she I think she hates it  even more than I do I would take John to  karaoke of any all of his friends John  was in acapella so they are very those  pitch-perfect movie type of people and  for a living but they're all like just  you know amateurs that used to sing in  college they all love karaoke and we  hate it so there you have it in the  music issue with a musician and a model  the two worst dates I have will be  having music anything